il fai così grosso dell'ariston che
figata
allora mi ero messo per prima così io
devo un po rompere il ghiaccio
sono contento ci sono tante donne e
anche tanti uomini tra l'altro volevo
raccontare insomma quello che sono io
che sono una donna non sembra e sono
contenta di essere una donna però ogni
tanto vorrei essere un uomo per farmi i
complimenti e dirmi ciao bella [ __ ]
oppure per chiedermi cosa fai stasera e
ic cosa fai
no sto a casa tolgo la pelle peperoni
prendermi st soddisfazione qualche non
sto a casa a purgare i colombi così
domani mattina mi sveglio sembra che
abbia nevicato
sono contenta di essere una donna non
l'ho mai avuta l'invidia del pene
nostalgia qualche giorno 6 ma in libia
proprio
è un bell articolo è per carità
divertente quando vuole poi è mutevole
come il cielo d'irlanda volte i miei
come i fondi di caffè a volte è noioso
come il bastone degli alpini a volte e
triste come mogol senza battisti a volte
proprio fiero come l'ultimo dei mohicani
ma non mi interessa assolutamente e poi
non mi piace neanche quando dicono a che
brava che sei sei veramente una donna
con le palle
a me quella roba lì non so a voi ma a me
la donna con le palle non mi piace
perché io ho le tette mi basta nomi
avanzano tra l'altro sono due anche
quelle quindi non è un problema io
infatti non so come faccia la merkel è
anche la camusso che sotto deve avere un
astuccio di bocce da 6
insomma abbiamo le tette non abbiamo
anche il cervello un po più piccolo
rispetto a quello degli uomini questo
voi lo sapevate cioè la mia ce l'ha più
grosso il cervello e pensa di essere più
intelligente
ecco allora le cose sono andate così che
quando il creatore ha fatto l'uomo e la
donna l'ha fatta con la quantità di
cervello uguale solo che mentre la donna
andava veniva beveva le sorgenti
schivava i dinosauri si riparava nelle
caverne mangiava le barche l'uomo non
l'uomo era un cretino
l'uomo si attaccava la quale dei mammut
sbatteva contro i rami bassi i serpenti
li mangiava direttamente dalla coda e le
bacche invece di metterli in bocca le
metteva nel retto pensando di essere una
slot machine
allora il creatore detto beh allora
aggiungiamo gli un po più di cervello e
così viene aggiunto ancora un po è un
certo punto è scoppiato un temporale e
mentre la donna si riparava dentro la
caverna l'uomo uscito fuori il capodanno
allora lee il creatore ha capito che non
poteva giungere gliele dell'altro che
doveva fare con quello che c'era se lo
doveva fargli la testa lunga
come homer simpson ed ecco spiegato
perché l'uomo aa più cervello no sono
contenta di essere una donna di essere
una donna anche di spettacolo perché ci
sono anche dei bellissimi modelli
femminili nel mondo dello spettacolo
c'è la chiabotto che beve l'acqua
elimina l'acqua che fa tanta plin plin
la marcuzzi che mangia il bifidus e
ritrova la sua naturale regolarità 70
plon plon speriamo che non facciano mai
lo spot insieme perché sono l'impianto
di concerto
dirige il maestro vessicchio
[Applauso]
no è quello che non mi piace è spesso
nelle donne di spettacolo quelle che
magari hanno anche raggiunto successo
non si capisce come per due doti credo
quella davanti a quella dietro che
quando sono intervistate da questi
giornalisti
rispondono così allora il giornalista
chiede com'è arrivata al successo ho
fatto tanta gavetta
ecco allora io volevo dire una cosa ma
ce ne fosse una una di quelle lì perché
non è che stiamo tutte così è una parte
così l'altra una di quelle lì che dica
come sono arrivata sono rotolate da un
lenzuolo all'altro finché sono caduta in
quello giusto come come sono realtà
sociale o data via lodata vi guarda che
sarebbe veramente innovativo è altro che
ted come se lo date via l'ho detta via
san frontiera rotto data via come guarda
il granturco e piccione di piazza san
marco cioè come le casse di minerali ai
profughi
proprio ai presenti lana secondo sparge
il sale in inverno così senza neanche
controllare e cioè proprio c'è stato un
traffico lì sotto come nella piazzetta
di capri a ferragosto proprio se c'era
da darla una volta la devo anche due per
precauzione guarda quando i giornalisti
fanno quelle belle domande del tipo ma
qual è il tuo peggiore difetto perché i
giornalisti fanno le domane il loro
fanno la faccia della gioconda che ha
preso la purga il mio peggior difetto
mi piace leccare lo zucchero a velo dei
crafen il mio peggior difetto credere
ancora tanto nell'amicizia ma capisci da
una una che di camion pezone tiro tiro
di coca tiro di coca che è un casino
guarda
scopo smanettata un dobermann e mi
faccio le gare alla testiera del letto
con gli fili dei freni della bici a
pranzo se non vedo il fondo del
bottiglione di vino da 2 litri non son
contenta e a natale mi vesto da
chierichetta il limone con mio zio che
ho un diacono laico o una che dicesse
così è anche c'è anche un altro momento
in cui la donna è particolarmente
ipocrita e e quando si rifà adesso c'è
la moda di di rifarsi nome non c'è
nessuna che lo dice no e anzi al
contrario e tu devi prima una aveva 50
anni dopo una settimana ne ha trenta ma
impossibile prima aveva le borse di
louis vuitton sotto gli occhi giorno
dopo liscia come un patinoire proto era
un velluto mille cost e poi una padella
antiaderente aveva le palpebre tutte che
ci voleva l'avvolgibile per tirarle su
il giorno dopo arriva con i bulbi di
frankestein e poi anche lì se il
giornalista chiede mani
qual è il segreto di questa eterna
giovinezza di questa pelle così fresca e
lor vece di guardarmi sono fatto un po
di cose tornò in segrete della mia
giovinezza questo appelli così fresca
stile di vita sano e qualche integratore
ma [ __ ] wow
ma quale stile di vita sano ma
impaziente al giorno prima ci aveva il
naso come depardieu a panino aq lento di
neonato giorno dopo ce l'hai tutto
all'insù come la tour eiffel e lo stile
di vita sano cos'è il gioco dell'oca
dove loca sono io cioè suggerito sulla
fronte e umida giocondo oppure le labbra
non si l'ombra e queste labbra
bellissime vedo queste labbra che poi
non riesco neanche più a parlare
sembrano i cammelli da questi ladri
questi capri e mangio moltissimi
christie di crusca sentito come le
regole migliore ma come cristina farmi
capire ma anch'io faccio lo stile di
vita sano
eppure ciò delle rughe che sono non
sembrò il canale di panama qua in mezzo
non so che se succede si forma questa
ruga qua in mezzo che un colpo di
machete praticamente ce l'abbiamo
tantissimo io la fornero e poi ho notato
l'altra domenica ligabue
si è incredibile però così oppure si
rifanno le tette giorno prima sono
praticamente piatte piatte che cioè dei
vassoi praticamente si possono fare che
cosa fai premi l'aereo non o vado via
fax e il giorno dopo però sgonfiate con
l'elio ma una volta dire la verità la
verità normale dire sì sì o no mi sono
fatto un po di ialuronico mi sono
sbottonata mi faceva cagare e quindi ho
trovato questa soluzione
no perché poi dicono alle donne ma
l'importante non è essere belle fuori
maestre belle dentro
è quanto mai dentro dove del colon
dopo è anche importante essere belle
fuori e per i maschi e più semplice per
le donne noi ogni tanto vorrei
svegliarmi la mattina e di avere non so
il culo di penelope cruz
il corpo di cameron diaz e le tette
della cucinotta e invece poi mi guardo e
ciò
il culo così di bruno vespa al corpo di
mentana e le tette di giacobbo e no poi
dicono ma no ma non è importante essere
belle è no allora chiariamo è importante
essere belle è una cosa [ __ ] chi a
quella dottrina deve sfruttare è una
comodità ma in tante piccole cose per
esempio se tu buchi la ruota della
macchina se sei bella torni a casa anche
con le mani pulite e sfiniscono da oggi
devi lordare tu se caschi per la strada
se sei bella qualcuno ti tira su 66
brutta tv ti fanno il video lo m su
youtube capito no bisogna essere bisogna
essere fighi ecco non belli fidi fighi
cioè riuscire a fare quello che si vuole
a spremersi a tirar fuori a scoprire
quali sono le lampadine che abbiamo
dentro e accenderle non è semplicissimo
è ma è quello che dobbiamo fare e
dobbiamo fare i conti anche con il
nostro passato in fondo noi abbiamo
fatto tanta strada noi dobbiamo essere
delle brave mogli delle brave
compagni delle bravi amiche delle brave
madri una volta dovevamo anche arrivare
vergine al matrimonio no con la jolanda
ancora nel cielo fanno adesso per
fortuna non è più così però ancora
ancora alcune donne ci tengono ed è una
scelta che rende il compito a noi di
spettatrice più oneroso ricco di impegni
però va benissimo io lo dico quelle che
insomma ancora non hanno non credo e
perché vede noi però conservarla non
paga secondo me perché come se quando
mettere i soldi in banca come i bot
lasci lire poi alla fine quanto ti danno
di interesse zero virgola zero dopo un
po si deprezza anzi scade come la lira
non vale più che non è come una
bottiglia di barbera che la metti lì 23
anni dopo la scaraffia è una goduria o
la toma che per col tempo mi ha un po
come il tartufo che lo lasci lì dopo un
po se non lo mangi
e poi anche per gli uomini dico che
soddisfazione c'è a fare l'amore per la
prima volta che una donna che non ha mai
fatto l'amore con una vergine è una
fatica e come quelli che ha dato il
primo colpo di piccone per fare il
tunnel del monte bianco
c'è chi se la gode di più quelli che
scavano il tunnel o quel che ci vanno
avanti indietro sciare a chamonin cioè
no per dire no è complicato e anche
faticoso meglio qui c'è chi è che ha
fatto meno fatica c'è quello che
percorre il sentiero che già segnato da
altri fare l'amore con una donna per la
prima volta è un po come andare alla
rinascente in tempo di saldi sito si sta
stretti e ti senti soffocare però le
donne fanno ancora fatica soprattutto
quando riesce già la e o sono più due
minuti 40 mi sembra di avere facce devo
proprio finire non posso andare avanti
no allora devo finire taglio tutto vado
avanti
volevo dire due cose ancora una cosa che
mi diceva sempre mia nonna che quando la
di ceo di ciò la nonna la cosa mi segni
che cosa orribile ed è questa che per
fare durano una coppia diceva per far
dorare
trimonio bisogna mordere l'aglio e dire
che è dolce e riceve ma che insegna
mentore peel hunt e non è invece col
passare del tempo io adesso 49 anni e
sto insieme un balengo da una vita mi
sono accorta che è proprio così che ogni
tanto per far durare le coppie anche non
solo le coppie e sentimentali ma anche
le coppie di lavoro bisogna a mordere
l'aglio lasciar passare che passi
lasciare che passi la bufera non stargli
sempre a rompere le scatole perché ogni
fuoco come dicono i napoletani cenere
diventa l'altra cosa e me lo dice la mia
amica ida che è vecchia come la
penicillina dice che non bisogna mai
lasciarsi sfuggire le occasioni perché
poi il tempo passa e non ai non sei più
in tempo ti viene poi il culo secco come
un cantuccio e non te ne puoi fare più
niente e che nell'amore bisogna anche un
po accontentarsi che non vuoi dire
rassegnarsi accontentarsi e che agli
uomini mi dice lei dopo una certa età
non viene più duro niente tranne l'aorta
e da ultimo volevo raccontare una cosa
che era successa un po di tempo fa a che
tempo che fa erano venuti ospiti dario
fo e franca rame e mi ricordo che franca
rame disse una cosa bellissima di se io
non so se morirò prima di dario quello
che so è che farò scrivere sulla sua
tomba questa frase come era vivo da vivo
e io volevo augurarlo a tutti voi di
essere vivi da vivi
[Applauso]